le problème en france c'est beaucoup
plus sérieux beaucoup plus grave et ne
se limite pas aux incivilités mais à la
violence qui s'est installée à
l'ensauvagement disent même certains et
je ne peux pas ne pas penser à cette
jeune policière où elle se joue faire de
bus où hier encore aux pompiers qui a
été agressée donc on voit bien il ya
quand même 110 agression de policiers de
forces de l'ordre par jour en france
voilà le noyau dur du problème tel qu'il
existe dans notre pays et au fond jean
castex a dressé le constat de l'échec de
trois ans de politiques en la matière et
je pense qu'il faut des mesures très
résolus mais je suis assez préoccupés
parce qu' une des premières actions ont
fait un des premiers déplacements du
garde des sceaux a été d'aller visiter
une prison et se réjouir qu elle ne soit
pas aussi peuplé que cela donc on sait
qu'on a un problème d'exécution des
peines dans notre pays on sait quoi
c'est aussi un problème c'est aussi un
problème mais enfin madame bello bella
la résolue en faisant sortir de prison
traitement treize mille détenus
je crois pas que ce soit véritablement
la solution et dire affirment est
clairement une stratégie et une doctrine
en faveur de l'orne et moi ce que j'ai
constaté depuis trois ans c'est que très
souvent et c'est ça va être un des
prennent de jean castex la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale est une majorité
de gauche qui est très réticente sur les
questions de sécurité d'immigration de
séparatisme la gauche inverse ya un mois
y a qu'à voir la loi asile et
immigration qui était censé résoudre le
problème notamment en matière
d'immigration régulière et régulière
elle a aggravé la situation elle l'a
aggravée